whether your first glimpse of we happy
few is at e3 this year or in three of
last year when it's truly first debuted
chances are it was head turning but not
particularly revealing us to have the
game blade
we saw clown-faced people messed up on
some drug called joy and got the
distinct feeling that things were far
from right in this ultimate retro
futuristic version of 1960s England
obviously it's early days as the game
has just arrived on Steam early access
and in my experience so far the game is
kind of riddled with bugs that said I am
finding the game world intriguing enough
to push through at the start of the game
you can opt not to take your joy but
then you'll find yourself facing off
against the drug-addled inhabitants of
Wellington wells and branded as a downer
this is where the game really begins
you'll start off in the garden district
where all of the donors or wastrels have
been segregated into a dilapidated part
of town away from the rainbow roads and
skipping civilians in the village of
Hamelin to call the wastrels Downers may
actually be an understatement you're
regularly accosted by people telling you
to [ __ ] off and similar delightful
salutations while your protagonist
Arthur Hastings occasionally muses to
himself about his depressing predicament
interestingly the game is described as a
survival roguelike and it features a
procedurally generated town before I got
my hands on the early access build this
seemed like a massive shame to me as
survival roguelikes usually result in
you dying constantly since we happy few
is full of quests to complete and things
to do I was not into the idea of
frequently losing my progress when I
actually got into the game though the
roguelike permadeath mechanic mostly
just led me to be more cautious I never
lost progress as a result of it a big
cushion for the game's Palmer death
mechanic is the second wind feature
which lets you get back up after your
health is completely depleted after
which you have a short window of time to
heal from your injuries or run away and
find something to heal you up it's worth
noting that as of the latest build both
perma death and second wind are optional
mechanics and are both on by default
while you will want to be careful this
isn't the sort of roguelike where you
can expect to be
every 20 minutes because of little
mistakes that said I'm an overly
cautious player in survival games my
friend died to starvation food poisoning
and the plague during his time with the
game so you may need to watch out a
little more depending on your playstyle
you will need to constantly turn to your
vitals if you want to survive Arthur
needs food water and sleep and if it
gets hurt you'll need to heal him up if
Arthur is hungry thirsty tired or
wounded these will have lasting negative
status effects that can affect your
stamina and rate of fatigue among other
things you can also temporarily dose him
with the joy drug to blend in with the
joy junkies in the village of Hamelin so
you don't arouse suspicion fortunately
these aspects rarely felt aggravating
and instead encouraged me to always have
my mind on scavenging exploring new
areas and crafting new supplies wherever
possible crafting is another central
mechanic in we happy few you can make
everything from healing salves to new
clothes that will affect your conformity
stat which affects your ability to go
unnoticed as well as tools like lock
picks or weapons and devices that will
disarm traps you'll find blueprints to
learn to craft these things turn about
the game world and the supplies you'll
need to make them with of course Arthur
doesn't really earn anything so mostly
you'll be stealing like a lot of
stealing like when you would hit up the
weapons trader in Oblivion after closing
time and bag 20 shitty and daggers the
amount of glass bottles and empty pill
bottles your mass will be staggering
unlike Oblivion however we happy few has
no indicator of when you're hidden it
only tells you when you're already doing
something bad like holding a weapon or
breaking into a coin box so you'll
actually need to have a good look around
and make sure any NPCs are at the very
least facing away from you before you
pill for that [ __ ] lest you find
yourself sprinting away from their house
with some new bruises your inventory is
limited although you can expand it
slightly with collectable expansion
devices there's only so much you can
carry at one time your safe house does
include a personal safe that functions
as a stash point so like so many other
aspects of this game you'll just need to
think ahead and know your priorities the
same rule applies to combat where
and the best way of attacking was using
my stamina sparingly falling back
frequently and landing charged heavy
attacks preferably while wielding
something hefty stealth takedowns and
running and hiding are also valid
alternatives and if you only have one
opponent you can probably go to town
with well-timed punches and not die in
any case patience is key as is not
getting surrounded eventually you'll
need to make your way to the main city
to complete your main quest of escaping
Wellington world this is where things
get quite a bit more difficult you'll
probably find yourself running from
hoards of civilians and policemen
screaming that you're a downer at one
point or another this is where you'll
make use of your trap disarming devices
as many of the Hamline houses you want
to raid a riddled with traps
you'll also need Jimmy bars to break
into houses from the outside and if all
else fails you can pop a couple of joy
to get the crowd of shiny happy people
off your downer back if you don't have
any pills on you hightail it back to
down to town that works too we have a
few asks you to be careful
clever prostate stealthy occasionally
aggressive and just generally good at
improvising when things go wrong which
trust me they absolutely will the
easiest way to figure out if you'll
enjoy this one is if you were keen on
games like don't starve and say you're
being hunted it will be interesting to
see how replayable the game proves to be
when you do complete the main escape
quest but the fact that there are
multiple playable characters on the way
should hopefully help in that department
for now the tense moments are
challenging at completing quests and
crafting new items is satisfying and
while I personally found the game to be
pretty buggy in its current state even
being off your joy feels pretty bloody
good that feels better doesn't it
see